morning all we need to change the prime
minister
the words of former conservative
minister nick gibb who has this morning
become just the latest tory mp to hand
in a letter of no confidence in boris
johnson
it's another blow at the end of a fairly
torrid week for the pm with a steady
stream of backbenchers calling for him
to quit and five senior aides announcing
their departures from number 10 and this
morning fresh allegations about mr
johnson breaking covered rules on his
birthday our people in politics
correspondent nick martin has the latest
well the prime minister waking up to
more bad news this morning this time one
of his former ministers the former
school minister nick gibb has joined the
growing line of disgruntled tory mps to
issue a letter of no confidence mr gibb
writing in the telegraph this morning
described his constituents as being
furious he said
we need to face up to the hard truths to
restore trust we need to change the
prime minister he went on to say my
constituents are furious about the
double standards imposing harsh into my
mind necessary restrictions while at the
same time flagrantly disregarding those
rules within the fortress of downing
street it's pretty scathing stuff when
you consider that just a few hours
before on friday another conservative mp
aaron bell mp for newcastle underline
also wrote a letter of no confidence
just the other day in the comments he
stood up and was quite scathing towards
the prime minister referring to the to
the sacrifices that he'd made during
lockdown while at the same time the
prime minister was allegedly holding
parties at downing street now this all
culminates in a really terrible week for
the prime minister he lost five
senior aides within 24 hours he's now
facing a rebellion of the back benches
um it's now 14 mps who publicly called
for the prime minister to go nine have
written written letters of no confidence
and this morning the daily mirror have
printed pictures in which they claim uh
to show the prime minister holding a
beer at a party in downing street now we
asked downing street for a comment but
they said they had nothing to say about
it but a sky news source who was at that
party has told us that they did see the
prime minister with a beer in his hand
and that the official photographer was
uh was
moving his way around the party taking
pictures so all in all a pretty bad end
to the week and the prime minister will
be hoping that there's no more uh
letters of discontent emerging this
weekend and he'll be hoping for a
quieter week than he's already had
uh well joining us once again on the
programme mo hussein a former downing
street special adviser for uh some
conservative administrations mo good to
see you again um
we talked roughly this time last week
and there have been a few events that
have i would suggest perhaps served to
increase the pressure on the prime
minister what is your assessment uh of
his potential longevity in number 10
well i think it's now incredibly time
limited this week has been uh body blow
after body blow um
i think probably the the main events the
the strongest thing that he will have to
think about is the departure manila
mirza a close ally of 14 years and a
loyalist and for her to publicly call
him out on his uh remarks against
kirstama and to leave the government in
this way i think was unexpected for many
people and i think he will
be really really affected by the other
departures as well clearly not great i
mean the other people were more
implicated in the partygate
investigation and the allegations around
that and as much as the allies the prime
minister tried to put a positive spin on
this in terms of a big change narrative
a big reset moment
every day and you know on any given day
we're hearing more and more at this drip
trip of other letters and other
revelations it just makes it feel
increasingly unsustainable
well the the the problem was pretty
straightforward they they simply can't
spin the meniere mirza a departure in
the same way that they did his chief of
staff his pps is director of
communications she made it very clear
and others suggest that there may be
other reasons lurking in the margins
about the marginalization of the policy
unit but she made it clear that it was
his comments about jimmy savile and
their scurrilous nature
yeah indeed this this dead cat strategy
where the prime minister made this
comment to try and deflect attention
away from what was happening in number
10 and the parties clearly has come back
to bite and it's set to really low tone
of debate it's not the cut and thrust a
parliamentary debate a lot of people on
the conservative side myself included
did not like those comments at all and
don't think that's fitting with the
office of prime minister and that's some
lasting damage because someone like
manera is the really big policy brain of
the government and in the week that the
government was trying to shift the
conversation onto things like leveling
up white paper and put forward an agenda
mps watching this will be
more and more concerned not just because
people are
leaving but thinking about what other
things we will be pushing and talking
about and run up to the next election we
can't just talk about getting brexit
done we can't just dine out on winning
this significant majority
two years ago we have to look forward
and a departure like that i think will
be concerning
is it right in your assessment mode for
people to view
the chancellor rishi sunaka's as perhaps
on maneuvers at the moment he made those
very pointed remarks this week relating
to to the jimmy savelle uh nonsense uh
when he said you know it's i'll be
honest it's not something i would have
said he he put a very very clear bit of
water between himself and the prime
minister on this are we wrong to read
that as
perhaps the starting pistol being fired
no i think i think
being on maneuvers is a fair assessment
he's not the only one by the way i think
other ministers uh and back pension
peace doing the same thing but it really
points to the draining away of authority
in number 10 and of the prime minister
because you're seeing an increasingly
robust cabinet and people who are not
just willing to
go and defend something that is
indefensible and take a hit on their
personal credibility which we know
matters a lot to the chancellor but
they're becoming increasingly
silent and silent speaks volumes or just
not following the number 10 line and i
think
the the the the longer this goes on and
the more trouble the prime minister's in
more people around him will will behave
like that because you're almost exacting
a price for your support with your
backbench mp or if you're a cabinet
minister you you're looking at the
future and thinking about what might
come next and do you really want to be
on camera or in public having said
something that you might come back to
regret in a few weeks or months time
what then more do you make of the
appointment of andrew griffith this is
the new head of the the policy and of
course andrew was formerly a very senior
executive here at sky he's
only recently become a member of
parliament we should say and and the
suggestion from some conservatives is
that during his time as pps well he he
just didn't handle the politics
particularly well
well
exactly and i think there's another
suggestion as well which is the prime
minister's just replacing old friends
with new friends he's very in the wheel
to the prime minister and is this really
the big reset moment that mps have been
promised there's a lot of talk about
mp's becoming more plugged into number
10. i think that is a good thing and i
think those relationships have uh soured
of late but it perhaps not perhaps not
the kind of big name that people might
have been expecting to really oversee
and help drive forward this operation i
think that leads to the wider question
with all these departures and with this
sense of chaos who would actually want
to go and work there
now people will be thinking about
their own lives their families their
future careers and if you can't
attract the right people then the change
narrative does start to fall flat i take
it you're not putting your own cv and
then well from what you've just said
yeah well you don't need to answer that
one
i'm always saying it's great to have you
on the program again take care we'll
speak soon thank you
and we will of course have much more on
that story throughout the morning at
five past eights we'll be hearing uh
from the labour side of the chamber the
shadow culture secretary lucy powell
and then just after nine the culture
secretary dean doris will be on the
program and in just a few minutes time
we'll also be speaking to dr liam fox
now trolls who send threatening messages
could go to jail as the government adds
new offences to its online safety bill
social media companies will also be
forced to take down harmful content as
part of the legislation this guy's
melina veselynovic joins us from the
newsroom at plenty for us to talk about
milena when i speak to the culture
secretary just a little bit later on
certainly and one of the biggest
differences i think in this bill is that
previously tech firms could wait until
harmful or legal content was flagged to
them before taking it down whereas now
the onus is really on them to be
proactive and deal with it before users
are exposed and not compliant firms
could be fined up to 10
of their worldwide turnover and
potentially even blocked from being
accessed in the uk now the government is
also adding three new offenses which
they say will be fit for the internet
age the first one is designed to deal
with things like online threats to rape
kill inflict physical violence the
second one should make it easier to
pursue and prosecute online abusers and
better address forms of violence against
women and girls in the third one will
deal with things like hope bomb threats
as well as the spread of covet 19
misinformation now in a statement the
culture secretary nadine doris said we
are listening to mps charities and
campaigners who have wanted us to
strengthen the legislation and today's
changes mean we will be able to bring
the full weight of the law against those
who use the internet as a weapon to ruin
people's lives and do so quicker and
more effectively however labour has said
that the bill needs to go further and
actually implement tougher sentences and
fines against a senior executives of
these tech companies who are
non-compliant they say that if it
doesn't potentially these big tech firms
won't stand up and take notice
milena thank you
also making the news this morning the
former u.s vice president mike pence has
denied claims by donald trump that he
could have overturned the results of the
2020 election in a speech in miami mr
pence denied the allegations that as
vice president he had the power to
prevent joe biden from taking office
president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
moroccan rescue workers are edging
closer to reaching rayne the trapped
five-year-old boy who fell into a
hundred foot deep well in northern
morocco on tuesday
the rescue operation now in its fourth
day involves digging out the land around
the well
rem does have tubes carrying air and
water but he himself can't be reached
because the well is just too narrow
the second stage of the rescue operation
is going on now we are racing against
time we need to reach rayan and we hope
to god we can
we hope that nothing will happen to the
rescue team from falling dust or any
obstacles regarding the boy's health
there is nothing new but we have hope
from god
a uk ticket holder has won the
euromillions jackpot of
109.9 million pounds a single player
matched all five euromillions numbers as
well as the two lucky star numbers to
scoop the top prize the lucky winner
becomes the 11th biggest winner ever
camelot is urging all players to check
their tickets because
it hasn't yet been claimed
if i'm not here at 8 o'clock you know
why ah now this week the government
announced plans to reverse the
controversial decision to impose a
vaccine mandate on all nhs and care
staff in england for many in the
industry already working with
understaffed teams the u-turn will be a
relief but for others
it has come too late sky's dan whitehead
reports from gloucester
we joined dylan on one of his last ever
shifts as a carer
after eight years he's decided to leave
good morning
you're right yeah how's it going
same as usual good it's a job that he
loves but he wanted the vaccine to be a
personal choice
unjabbed he reluctantly handed in his
resignation it was hard sending that in
but um
i guess i had to do what was best for me
and we were put in a position where you
either had the vaccine
or you leave so i couldn't wait
until the last date and then have no
income
for dylan the government's plan to now
reverse mandatory vaccination for nhs
and home carers in england comes too
late definitely didn't want to go so how
do you feel when you found out that you
had to make this decision because i was
an absolute kick in the teeth um
worked hard last two years
um
to then be told either have this vaccine
or go
so yeah
not feeling good about it it's not not a
good decision
with nearly 80 000 nhs workers
unvaccinated like dylan the government
had little choice
natural curves of the knee natural
curves of the lumbar spine and natural
curves of the neck at the care company
which employed him the push to get new
staff signed up is relentless
it's easy to understand the growing
demands on the nhs and social care
system this company is training 20 new
staff every single week just to cope
with the growing number of patients
so this friday i could possibly
move it till about 11 45 and that's all
right
the 11th hour u-turn takes pressure off
a sector already under strain we will
always support the vaccination program
and i think we should all suggest to be
vaccinated so i think that's important
in our industry but i also think that
it's not it can't be a factor the
industry is into so much pressure it's
so understaffed in from sort of care
homes thompsonville care and hospitals
hospices we're all understaffed but the
issue isn't over another more dangerous
strain of kovid 19 could see the
frontline vaccination debate erupt all
over again
each time carers like dylan leave an
industry
that can ill afford to be understaffed
dan whitehead sky news in gloucester
other news and staff at rupert murdoch's
news corporation have been targeted by a
cyber attack investigators believe it
was linked to china and affected a
limited number of individuals working
for outlets including news uk publisher
of the times and the sun
the comedian jimmy carr has been widely
criticized for a disparaging joke about
the deaths of thousands within the
travelling community during the
holocaust
he made the comments in his latest
netflix special his dark material
the traveler movement which supports
travellers in the uk
called the joke truly disturbing
iceland has announced that it plans to
end whaling by 2024 as one of the few
countries that still hunts wales
commercially its food minister says the
demand for whale meat has plummeted and
that whaling is no longer profitable
this weekend the queen celebrates the
70th anniversary of her accession to the
throne which followed the death of her
father king george in june of course
there will be huge celebrations for her
platinum jubilee but to mark her
accession day her majesty has invited us
all to join her looking through family
heirlooms and archived items center over
the years for past jubilees skies
rhiannon milks reports
these are all for the golden jubilee
and the recipe mentions the main
qualities for the perfect queen it's
funny the things she's been sent over
the years that's very fun isn't it
i could encourage a lot of hard work and
a dash of loyalty a recipe for the
perfect queen just one of the items
stashed away from past jubilees
so they've all been kept
somewhere
they will all be preserved in the
archives
as this weekend she prepares for the
beginning of her platinum jubilee year
simple but ingenious which includes a
competition to find a new pudding
i've also got we've had a number of
platinum pudding competition entries
that have been coming in in recent weeks
so people are being very
creative there's all the ingredients oh
i see the truth yes there's a number of
recipes
for the queen the start of any jubilee
year always comes with mixed feelings
sunday will mark 70 years since her
father died a king who had indeed spent
his strength in the selfless service of
his people
seven decades since she became queen
marking the start of an extraordinary
reign
her platinum jubilee will be a first for
any british monarch a milestone not even
queen victoria managed this fan from
victoria's golden jubilee certainly
seemed to catch her attention in some
ways a rare royal autograph book signed
by victoria's extended family including
the future monarchs king edward vii and
tsar nicholas ii of russia and it's
still shut
yes it was beautiful
oh good well that's very interesting to
see this summer we will again see big
celebrations
[Music]
for now someone else needs the queen's
attention i know what you want
rhiannon mills sky news
time for a quick look at the weekend
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
the rain will spread south today with
wintry showers following into the windy
northwest later many places will start
sunny with a frost and some icy
stretches but the milder northwest will
be wet and windy
clouds and patchy rain will spread
southwards during the morning but
central and southern england will stay
mainly dry and sunny the southeast coast
of ireland remaining largely fine too
welcome back at the conservative party
is currently gripped by an internal
struggle as mps disagree over whether
boris johnson should continue his leader
in a speech later today the former party
chairman dr liam fox will set out his
principles on how the party should be
governed and i'm very pleased to say
that dr fox joins us now very good to
see you and thank you so much for
joining us on a saturday um just give us
a flavor of what you'll be saying in
your speech just a little bit later
today you're the keynote speaker at the
south west conservatives conference um
down in devon and and in essence you're
you're setting out europe the principles
that define conservatism as you see them
yes and i think that there needs to be a
higher level of debate in our in our
politics in britain uh and you know as i
have said for a long time it's not
anything uh groundbreaking or new there
are basic principles attached to
conservatism relating to um the the need
for the security of the country to be
the top priority the need to protect
freedom of speech they need to ensure
opportunity they need to keep us on a
sound money low tax economy
and and i'm saying these things because
just talking to
uh a lot of our party activists there's
a desire to get away from
uh
not just
the uh debate around quote with the
number 10 but to get back to really
defining issues uh in our politics and i
think that's a it's something that
occurs not just in the united kingdom
but talking to my colleagues in the u.s
i think that's also a debate that they
want to have how do we reinvigorate our
debate and a lot of things that with all
people in our age group may take a lot
of these arguments for granted and a lot
of conservatives regard them as
self-evident truths but they do have to
be repeated particularly for a younger
generation that because it's uh very
involved in social media perhaps hasn't
had exposure to the same sort of
philosophical approach politics that we
used to uh expect in the past
of course the timing of this conference
was long set in stone before of course
the events of the past couple of weeks
but reading through some of the comments
that you made it it does feel perhaps as
if you're alluding towards the the
current situation i mean you start your
speech
as i understand it to say that saying
this to be a conservative is not just a
convenient label to have on your ballot
paper a banner slapped on any old
collection of ideas it is not a vehicle
for personal ambition without a price
tag it comes with a built-in set of
values and beliefs i mean i might be
reading too much into dr fox but that
could be read as a veiled criticism of
perhaps the man at the top of the party
at the moment
i don't think that is a correct
interpretation but um you know it would
be quite wrong with me to pretend that
there isn't a debate about the future of
the conservative party or the leadership
of the conservative party and i think
it's worth just making the point
um to
those who would
push the prime minister aside that
this is not just about
personalities it's also what the party
believes and um the conservative party
is much older and stronger than any
individual and as i say it does come
with a set of baked in
beliefs so i think it's part of a wider
debate uh i it's as you say this was a
conference that has been
put
into practice a long time before we got
to the current covert debate on what
happened that didn't happen in downing
street and i think that if anything has
actually reinforced the view that we
need to talk about the bigger issues and
not just to concentrate if you like on
the
on the day-to-day politics that people i
think are looking for
guidance and as we go into a period
where you know the economic certainties
are not so great because we've seen the
rise of inflation we've seen interest
rates rise this week we've seen the
crisis in ukraine rising where i think
at the salience of security and defense
is important one of the problems
that i've been making is that when there
is demand for
uh big spending and a whole range of
areas in welfare and health and so on
that cannot come at the expense of our
security and i think that the the crisis
in ukraine it also gives
as i said an increased salience to that
argument
but you're an old hand you you
understand and have worked in politics
for longer than most
and whilst it's not necessarily always
fatal when the rot sets in it can be
very very difficult to deal with so just
in
in straightforward terms do you feel
that boris johnson
can continue enroll as leader of the
conservative party and prime minister do
you think that this week he has
demonstrated an ability to take control
of the situation given all the
resignations that took place in the past
couple of days
well in the last few days i think that
there has been a necessary clear out in
number 10 but it also needs to come with
the change of culture in number 10 as
i've said before but i think that the
prime minister uh allowed himself to be
persuaded by an advisor or advisors that
there should be a sort of winner takes
all culture in number 10 and i think
it's very important the prime ministers
build bridges across
whatever party it is that they lead i
think that they need to include in their
their senior year
so of government people who won't agree
with them who challenge what they think
i think that leads to better decision
making and i hope that what we're seeing
this week is is the prime minister doing
just that i mean boris johnson knows
he's been arched by a number of senior
colleagues to improve the quality of the
running of number 10 as i say not just
in the structure but the culture
we look at a couple of the people that
have that have put their heads above the
parapet david davis a man you know very
very well of course i'm not sure whether
or not he submitted his letter of no
confidence to the 22 but you know he did
basically call on the prime minister to
go at pmq's nick gibb again a man i'm
sure that you you know not known as
someone uh
for for throwing his toys out of the
pram i mean when you're seeing figures
as solid and as senior as mr gibb and mr
davis being as explicit
it still does feel as though the prime
minister has an awful lot to do
to persuade the party that you know he
is the right man to continue
well i think that if you with all due
respect and i understand why the media
do this the report the people who are uh
going on the record as being unhappy but
you've got to remember that the party
hasn't the parliamentary party hasn't
reached even the 15 threshold required
for a confidence but which suggests that
85 of our parliamentary colleagues um
are waiting to see what happens and i
think that prime minister is still being
given the benefit of the doubt there are
obviously questions to be answered when
we get the police report into what
happened in number 10 and i think that
we have to wait and see what that says
and there's no point in keeping talking
about things when there's nothing new to
say i think the prime minister's got an
opportunity to show that he can build
bridges across the party that he can
improve the running of number 10 that
there's a better understanding of what
the parliamentary party
wants and actually get on with
delivering
on our manifesto as well as dealing with
these big issues
which are not necessarily
we
anticipated
uh in 2019 at the general election when
we hadn't had the coverage seen the
increased saber rattling by by russia so
i think that we do need political
stability at the present time as i've
argued as you know that this is not the
time for you know a leadership election
three months of naval gazing by the
conservative party and as i have been
saying in this speech and in this
conference we have to always ensure that
it's country first that is party second
and personal ambition third
liam fox great to see you this morning
thanks very much for joining us thank
you nice to see
now in
1915 the explorer anna shackleton sailed
his ship the endurance through the
waters of antarctica
until it was engulfed by ice and sank
now more than 100 years later a team of
modern adventurers scientists and
technicians
are setting out to find the wreck
we can speak now to the historian dan
snow who is part of the mission dan
great to see you this morning and can i
say have we set sail just yet
we are now about 10 to 20 meters off the
key in cape town so you are we are in
the process all happening around me
we're in the process of setting said
it's the perfect timing
perfect sky news we love a bit of live
television breaking news and all the
rest of it great to have you on this
morning dan
explain exactly what it is that this
mission will be doing everyone knows the
tales of shackleton and what went on in
the antarctic and of course the name
endurance is one which which which lives
long long after um it's sinking but but
is there going to be anything left to
find
well
good question we think there is and uh
insurance is certainly the most
probably most remote and difficult to
find historic shipwreck on planet earth
it's in the weddell sea it's three
thousand meters down the surface that we
will see is a giant
moving shifting morass of ice flows that
crushed endurance and could imprison
even a ship as as big as this but 3000
meters down it's obviously very very
cold there are very very very few
organisms that feed on wood down there
because there's no wood traditionally to
be fed on so that we believe that the
hull of the ship will be quite intact
we're hoping to see endurance as we drop
these two unmanned vehicles 3000 meters
down to scour the seabed to make a
survey of the seabed we don't know
exactly where it sank but we're down
there for a week 10 days and we've got
several opportunities to try and find it
i mean three thousand meters i mean it's
a it's an awful lot of depth that you're
gonna have to to deal with how exactly
are you going to be doing that
submersibles
yes unmanned submersibles um my kids ask
me if i'm going diving on it but i have
to reluctantly admit that i'm admitted
i'm not unmanaged the muscles tethered
by a 25 kilometer optic fiber cable an
umbilical cord that attaches from those
submersibles to this ship above so we
can get almost real-time data as it's
scouring the seabed so they're they're
the secret weapon in this search and
they'll be conducting a search pattern
across this great area of ocean really
no very modern certain bring no modern
surveys to that seabed have ever
occurred before so there's a really
interesting scientific and sort of
discovery aspect this exploration as
well
well
as a historian what is it about the
story of ernest shackleton of the
endurance that that most grabs you i
mean i said at the outset of our
interview everyone knows the story but
perhaps some people don't so perhaps you
could just give us a little bit of a
backstory to it all
well for those who don't know the story
enjoy what follows it's the greatest
story of survival in in british i think
probably world history they take
endurance down to the ice it gets
trapped they spend the winter traps and
drinks on the ice it then gets crushed
they move it sinks they move and live on
the ice on icecap on the scene they live
on ice that starts to melt and break up
they take to their small rowing boats
their lifeboats they row and sail
through hundreds of miles to an island
across the southern ocean called
elephant island it can't support life so
shackleton takes a crew of five people
with him and they sail 700 miles across
the southern ocean through hurricanes
and mountainous waves to south georgia
they land on south georgia they don't
have to conduct the first ever
human crossing of south georgia across
places and mountains in inappropriate
gear at the limit of their insurance
they get to wailing stations on the
other side of south georgia and can
finally send a boat back to rescue
everyone else it is the most
extraordinary story in our history
dan you're quite good at this
storytelling like i have to say um just
a final question though of course that
you you look back over 100 years now of
course uh between the sinking the
endurance and and today does the spirit
of adventure that ernest shackleton and
and the others had because of course
they were working with much limited
technique with limited technology no gps
no satellite no satellite phone to pick
up and get someone to come and rescue do
you think that spirit of adventure still
persists
i think it does but i want to say that
the spirit adventure persists when you
know you've got a warm bed to go back to
and you can
you can you can call sky news via our
satellite link and i can do my podcasts
and my tick tock and everything else so
yeah sure i'm very adventurous am i
adventurous compared to those people no
i'm not they they went down to the south
they were completely unsupported they
had to rescue themselves they had to
fashion there and escape except you know
work with what they had at hand they
went on limited rations they had they
were they they were at the very limit of
human um survival endurance so i i think
looking around me at this ship there's
loads of scientists here there's loads
of geographers uh marine archaeologists
they are in the spirit of the scientists
who went with shackleton we are still
learning so much about this planet we're
still discovering amazing fisheries in
the wedding sea we're still expecting to
learn a huge amount today on this
expedition so i think that spirit is
alive and well but of course
we do so in a far safer and more
comfortable way than they did just over
a hundred years ago
dan have a wonderful trip we will keep
fingers crossed that the endurance is in
fact found and hopefully we maybe have a
chat with you on the other side of the
discovery um dan snow thank you so much
for joining us
thank you
stick with us here on sky news breakfast
after the break another look at the
papers with the entrepreneur kate
hardcastle and the broadcaster pete
price
[Music]
time for another run through the papers
uh in the company of the entrepreneur
kate hardcastle and the broadcaster pete
price guys uh yeah well you've you've
changed pete you've changed i'm
definitely noticing something have you
got the sun bed on or something because
it's awfully orange where you are at the
moment i don't understand
let me just put this light off so that
works that's it perfect
all sorted brilliant that looks a lot
more natural okay you're looking fine so
we'll come to you first this time um
inside the telegraph nick gibb is an
interesting one as a minister he was
often the minister that was sent out to
deal with the broadcast interviews in
the morning you know you get to spend a
bit of time with these people before and
after the interviews you get a bit of an
idea for them nick gibb did not ever
strike me as someone who was prone to
throwing his toys out of his pram or
making a decision rashly and we perhaps
might want to look at what he's saying
about the prime minister in that light
he's been an mp since 97 he served three
mps and he's written what i feel is a
very balanced letter here to talk about
his reasons and why he feels johnson
should go and at the heart of this i
think there is clarity that this is
someone saying this is absolutely not
about cake beers how many parties it's
simply the fundamental philosophy of
telling the truth what is the right
thing to do authenticity and respect and
how can leaders ever expect that from us
as the public if they're not prepared to
deliver it to us in return and lead with
those values and i think it is
fair that we must have this conversation
i too am sick of the how many parties
were there how many investigations are
there going to be
but fundamentally people
lost
families let me put a very personal
slant on this
i have two six-year-old children it has
been a third of their life so far for
them not to connect and engage and
interact with their friends at school
for big periods of time we have to
understand the mark it has left on all
of us the imprint it's left on all of us
and realize that if our leaders were not
doing the right thing indeed doing the
opposite is what they were telling us to
do it is going to lead to scrutiny to
questions and we must have leaders in
the business world as well as in
government that do the right thing we've
got business leaders dealing with a sea
bed of issues right now years and years
of issues regards diversity inclusion
equality
community environment they're expected
to stand up to the plate our government
government must too yeah good point um
pete take us inside the guardian and
something that i i think may worry a lot
of people off gem suggesting that the
price cap could be changing every
quarter
and it's an interesting article but it's
also a very scary article we're saying
this because they say will help with
household
uh um
the way they they run their money the
way they budget the way they put it
together they said it will help it will
scare people to death what is also scary
in this is that um shell made their
biggest quality profits ever
a quarterly profit in eight years the
biggest ever now when the price is
dropped does the money ever come back to
us i think the word is no we never get
it and because of the volatility of
what's happened because of the pandemic
throughout the world we don't know where
we stand but we are all incredibly
vulnerable so it is frightening to think
that off gem are going to change this to
three months instead of six months but
do households need to know that but i
also think that any government around
the world should start taxing all these
companies because there's an awful lot
of people directors and uh
shareholders making vast amounts of
money and we've kept the oil and shell
and and and the the gas industry we've
kept them and put them where they are
today it's time for them to give
something back especially in britain to
the british public
if we might just skip ahead a couple of
stories and tell me about the jeff bezos
bridge what on earth is this all about
well the other story i was going to
cover was just how well amos are doing
this week particularly in the u.s stock
market where they have done uh performed
brilliantly compared to other tech
giants like meta but i think we have
this
character now in bezos that many people
feel frustrated about they want to see
him as this kind of villainous character
and and this is the story really leaning
into this that to allow his super yacht
which is 417 foot long to get from the
people that have built it into the ocean
a bridge has to be dismantled in
rotterdam what else are you going to do
if you are a billionaire apart from
demolished bridges to get your super
yachts out
we'll see you next time as well more
about the prime minister
[Music]